okay so this is out of the past and uh
we got mountains and we got flashbacks
good change it off thank you um it's a
good episode but um okay so a mom comes
in well first of all oh my god
when tarrlok tries to bend him and he
just walks through I mean that's like
one of the few bones or my choice just
like I took what is this guy IV I'm
fascinated by this guy and just what a
fuckin badass he is do um and okay so
you know and Karl Cora's got that great
scene where she figures out how to not
get electrocuted in the Box cooking can
she not metal Ben did it is that oh oh
no that's right yeah she's learning all
the pending I'm sorry uh but okay so she
can't get out of this box essentially
and she went earthbending one metal then
maybe I don't know maybe I missed
something but okay so she said this box
you very cleverly uses like her bandanna
whatever to hang on and breaks free
doesn't cool Kenny action sequence comes
up there's Armand and she just sees him
there and he sees her and she has this
look of fear and then just washes you
know lunges after him and all these
icicles and then Chuck things are going
to a mall the snows going in and he oh
he starts at dodging he jumps through
and he's going after her okay here we go
she runs the other way end of action
scene okay I kind of give it because
they built up the fear so when this
happens it's not like okay what come on
guys I mean I kind of get it but come on
I want to see this fight I want all I
see more than together I want to see
them talking more always be conversation
like what she had with Tarlac before
with that awesome waterfall and
everything uh but could just be there
building it up which I hope that's it
because when we got three more episodes
left I mean
running out of time guys let's get this
going
um I just want to see this stuff
happened uh but but okay so you got that
you got um uh you got Lin going off
chief Flynn right
uh you got her going off breaks the
other team members everything out of
jail they think the Equalists are behind
it they're not you know kidnapping Korra
they're not uh so they go up and
whatever find out that our lacks a blood
bender uh and he's he's the descendant
of a guy who could blood Bend in the
past and he did through like the crime
underground and now he's trying to seize
control through politics which in many
respects it's not that different so um
so I like that that that's a good story
for this guy a good backstory uh I enjoy
that a great deal and I liked him
getting his comeuppance
um and the flashbacks were good too I
like seeing sort of what happened to
everybody there um though if any was
supposed to be for tea he says they're
like you know 40 years old we stop with
the nicknames I mean shouldn't talk be
like 30 years something if we still set
a little high pitch to be 30 but I've
never gone but still still cool it's
cool to see them all there it's cool to
see them doing their cool stuff um they
made the blood vending like even
creepier like it opens up with like
gorgeous being brought in like it's just
totally you know just manipulated and
creep if I'd so it's so very cool I'm
glad they they took that even a little
further and I like that they explained
how he could sort of blood then even
without the full moon that there are
just sort of these anonymity anonomys
and their Anam differences mutants cuz i
can't talk right now
oh but yeah and i thought they had she
did a pretty good job of explaining that
and with very few sentences i thought
having grown up Sokka their sort
condense that down was actually pretty
effective um so yeah and I liked the
Polar Bear Dog
finding a quorum just like okay no that
works it you know sometimes I feel like
a lot what are the Ozma's know she's
tracking her I mean I got it
um more that don't love trying oh you
know what I'm just I'm gonna try that
does not to talk about it got you know I
don't like it so if it just assume it's
in like every episode if it gets like
really bad I'll talk about it but just
assume if there's a love triangle thing
in it I'm not gonna like it
um so yeah to try to think what else um
good episode I just wish maybe maybe a
little bit more of a battle like you
know I don't mind Cora running away but
maybe a little bit more confrontation
there especially after that bill Emma
she comes out of the door and just in
slow motion when you see him train and
it just looks really intimidating and
it's building up like there's gotta be
this big fight it starts to be a big
fight and she takes off it's like you
know that um what that solid minute
dedicated to that love triangle there
could've been a minute a fighting could
have made it better but no you had to
you have to do that so um hey what
triangle okay okay I I know everyone
else does too we're choice that they
went with um that they decided to do
that but but there it is um still good
episode still uh I still learn a lot
about about the past
I like seeing grown-up bang I like
seeing grown-up talk and it didn't it
didn't feel too much like bad fanfiction
it actually felt like no no this is
where they would be Sokka as the
congressman or whatever I didn't know
about him kind of like okay I'll buy
that enough um Rick guitar ook I go I
mean I I know she's in the first episode
uh but where was she again I I don't
know I cuz I know her and egg we're a
couple so it's like what was she doing
when he was doing all this leading the
city and the world stuff um mail ago
more into their or maybe they said and I
state could very well be um but now I'm
just rambling uh good one good a good
episode out of the past uh definitely
enjoyed it and uh can't wait to see more
of that battle I know it's coming come
on am encore let's go back back let's
fight not you know don't know who is
korimako where they gonna get together
the fuck that I'm on a clock let's go go
go go
you go bye